hurry Washington is a mom for the second
time the scandal star and her husband
and Nnamdi Asomugha welcomed a baby boy
earlier this month his name caleb
kolecki the couple already has
two-year-old daughter Isabel and last
month's Emmys Carrie opened up to et
about expanding at the family now have
you had to talk about a new sibling
arriving have you had that moment and
clarified that because it's don't advice
do you have advice about ours was we
brought a gift into the hospital and my
son was blown away that the baby would
bring him a gift I like getting send me
your thoughts and ideas yeah what what
what kind of advice have you been
getting I'm that kind of stuff you know
like having pictures of the kids you
already have in the room and that kind
of stuff you know you just want
everybody to know they they still have a
play yeah ya know it's hard because
everybody's like what's going on what's
that ma'am who's in there
I don't know myself no no you keep me in
a secret your weight
you